no
[Música]
el año pasado tuve un problema con
césped de mi jardín a principios de año
noté que había una zona en el césped que
era menos verde que el resto de mi
jardín cuando pregunté en latín
especialista me dijeron que debía usar
fertilizantes
seguir las instrucciones pero la zona
seguía menos verde que el resto así que
decidí usar un poco más a pesar que las
instituciones indicaban sólo una
aplicación por temporada
pasaron las semanas la zona se veía
incluso peor
así que regrese a la tienda y me
sugieran usar semillas para hacerte
parecer que ser pastor nuevo seguir las
soluciones pero nada la zona ahora
estaba marrón mientras que el resto de
mi gras estaba súper verde
hablar nuevamente con la tienda me
dijeron que tal vez la tierra estaba
muerta así que compré abono para robar
la tierra y de paso más semillas explicó
pero lo hice polonio que lo de puede que
esa área se volviera una desgracia de
barro
se habrán dado cuenta que jardinero no
soy
no tiene ni idea de que estaba pasando
hasta que un día soleado noté algo en
plena ola de calor con el sol
directamente hacia dónde estaba note que
la zona marrón estaba bajo una sombra
levante mi cabeza y me di cuenta que la
sombra era de los arbustos de atrás de
la casa
lo debe cortar esos arbustos esa zona
volvió a ser verde al cabo de unos días
cualquiera que escuche esto podrá darse
cuenta que si es que hubiese observado
bien el problema desde un principio
habría notado la sombra los arbustos y
subsecuentemente ahorrado todos los
productos que le eche al pobre césped
en este caso que podrá parecer simple
perdía algo de 150 soles en productos en
el jardín solo por no haber encontrado
la causa raíz del problema desde el
comienzo
pero en una empresa un problema mal o no
resuelto puede llegar a costar millones
de dólares en ventas perdidas mala
publicidad y hasta accidentes fatales en
los trabajadores o consumidores
por ejemplo en el 2008 más de 600
personas llegaron a enfermarse de las
cuales 8 murieron por consumir productos
contaminados con salmonela producidos
por la espina corporation of america una
empresa estadounidense que producía
productos a base de maní y nueces
este suceso resultó en uno de los más
grandes retiros de productos en la
historia de la industria alimentaria
costándole la compañía más de un billón
de dólares y subsecuentemente llevándola
a la quiebra
con ella miles de trabajadores perdieron
su trabajo
ahora en la manufactura las empresas
convierten materias primas a productos
que el consumidor o usuario confía y
está dispuesto a pagar por ejemplo
convierten la leche fresca de la vaca a
latas de leche condensada que muchos
usan esos postres
ahora cualquier persona o empresa
tenemos problemas
pero cuando millones de personas usan
tus productos millones de niños toman tu
leche cada mañana o millones de
trabajadores se suben al bus que tú
ayudas a crear es más que vital resolver
problemas efectivamente
tengo más de 12 años liderando y
enseñando programas de mejora continua
en manufactura de productos de consumo
masivo tales como helados chocolates
leche café y papel higiénico
de hecho es un milagro que no esté obesa
hasta ahora
en todo ese tiempo he llegado a la
conclusión que el 90% de los problemas
pueden ser resueltos efectivamente con
tres pasos básicos
y observar pensar actuar
observar pensar actuar
vayamos brevemente a cada paso
el primer paso y el más importante es el
observar alguna vez habrán escuchado el
dicho piensa antes de actuar pues déjeme
decirles que es muy cierto pero antes de
pensar hay algo incluso más importante
el observar
esto puede ser obvio pero no lo es
cuántas veces hemos mandado un mensaje
de whatsapp sin haberlo leído bien
este impulso a la acción es tan natural
en todos nosotros que ahora puedes
eliminar mensajes enviados en whatsapp
al observar el objetivo de este paso es
entender y focalizar el problema se
trata de poder simplemente describir
detalladamente el problema ahora como
sabemos que estamos entendiendo bien el
problema cinco preguntas claves el que
el cuando el quién el dónde el cómo sí
pueden descubrir algo nuevo
preguntándonos es como estas cinco
preguntas tienen más del 50 por ciento
del problema resuelto
una vez identificado el problema vamos
al segundo paso que es el pensar en ella
preguntamos por qué por qué por qué por
qué y por qué por lo menos cinco veces
para llegar a la causa de raíz
por ejemplo hace unos años el lincoln
memorial en eeuu en washington dc sufría
del problema de deterioro
ahora primero porque he sufrido el
problema deterioro porque constantemente
tenía que ser limpiado con químicos
detergentes los cuales eran abrasivos
y porque integrista limpiado con
químicos detergentes porque tenía una
gran cantidad de heces de aves
constantemente
porque había una gran cantidad de heces
de aves constantemente porque las aves
eran atraídas por la gran cantidad de
arañas
cuarto porque habían tantas arañas
porque había una gran cantidad de
insectos de las cuales las arañas
alimentaban
finalmente porque habían tantos insectos
porque esos insectos eran atraídos por
la luz del monumento
es así que usamos los cinco porque es
para encontrar la causa raíz
en este caso pudieron el problema
con algo que parecería no relacionado
como cambiar la luz del monumento
y luego identificar las causas raíces
vamos a tercer paso que es el actual
donde implementamos soluciones que
ataquen directamente la causa raíz del
problema los hemos sostenibles en el
tiempo y finalmente compartimos o
replicamos la solución a otros problemas
similares
ahora se preguntarán cómo es que tres
pasos pueden marcar la diferencia a la
hora de resolver problemas
primero el observador puede marcar la
diferencia entre decir encontré un
en mi país de manzana y encontré un
gusano dentro de un pedazo de manzana en
mi país
puedes ver que el primero nos podría
mandar inspeccionar toda la cocina
mientras que la segunda nos dice que es
muy probable que el gusano proviene de
una de las manzanas
otro ejemplo es mi jardín
hay una gran diferencia entre decir que
tengo una zona de migración de no crecer
en migración de lo que es el pasto y no
crece grasa en el rincón de mi jardín
donde los arbustos atrás le dan la
sombra durante todo el día pueden ver
que el problema es mucho más claro e
incluso mucho más fácil de solucionar
es así como con una buena observación
tenemos más del 50% del problema
resuelto
en el segundo caso es el pensar la
diferencia en ella es que profundizamos
en el problema para llegar la causa raíz
para ello usamos porque es por ejemplo
en la fabricación de chocolate usamos
bombas motorizadas para transferir
chocolate basta de un lugar a otro algo
parecido a las bombas que ustedes tienen
en esos edificios para llevar agua a los
pisos más altos
hace unos años el motor de las bombas de
paz del chocolate en mi fábrica que muy
repentinamente durante bombeo de
chocolate de un tanque alan y de
producción
ahora primero por qué por qué por qué la
bomba quemó
porque la pasta chocolate estaba más
espesa de lo normal
y porque estaba más especial o normal
porque el tanque de donde provenía no
tenía el temple correcta tercer porque
porque el tanque no tenía la temperatura
correcta
porque el termómetro del tanque no
estaba mandando la señal al calentador
del tanque
y porque no estaba mandado la señal al
calentador
porque el cable del calentador que
estaba en una caja había sido atrapada y
dañada por la tapa de la caja al
cerrarse luego de un mantenimiento
y porque el cable fue dañado por el que
tapa de la caja de cerrarse porque el
cable estaba suelto
pueden darse cuenta que en el pensar no
solo llegamos a la causa raíz sino que
hacemos el problema mucho más simple de
resolver es así que partimos desde algo
técnico como una bomba sobre saturada o
quemada y llegamos a algo tan simple
como es un cable suelto
finalmente en el actuar implementamos
soluciones que ataquen la causa raíz
en el ejemplo de la bomba simplemente
fue instalar un sujetador de cable para
que el cable siempre esté en una
posición adecuada pero la solución no
quede ahí aprendimos que tener estos
cables son un problema y así que
replicamos la misma solución a todas las
cajas de cables en la fábrica es así que
en el actuar no solo es solucionar el
problema sino también replicar
aplicaciones similares y asegurarnos que
el problema no vuelva a ocurrir
pero la belleza de desear pensar y
actuar no sólo está en resolver
problemas efectivamente
sino también en el hecho de que de
repente has descubierto algo que puede
que nadie haya descubierto antes de
repente sujetar cables significa que
hemos evitado un incendio en el futuro
en la fábrica de repente todo el sistema
ha dado un paso adelante
ahora implementando y enseñando esta
metodología en mi trabajo hemos podido
resolver miles de problemas y ahorramos
millones de dólares
les voy a contar un ejemplo el trabajo
mi fábrica es muy conocida en el reino
unido porque en ella fue inventado el
tofu y masticable esto fue más de más de
80 años
en la fábrica uno de nuestros productos
más importantes son las latas de
chocolate surtidos las cuales tienen una
forma característica octogonal
estas latas son tan infaltables en la
navidad británica como lo son los
panetones en el perú
hace dos años introducimos este diseño
para nuestras latas de chocolates
caracterizados por el color dorado y el
lazo púrpura en la línea de envasado de
envasado las latas son llenadas con su
cola surtidos luego son llevadas a las
máquinas etapa 2 el tapado se da cuando
la máquina detecta que dilata
las latas son detectadas por un sensor
que es como una especie de láser cuando
la lata llega a la línea de tapado el
láser es obstruido y eso le indica la
máquina que 1 lata ha llegado para ser
tapado
el problema que teníamos era que algunas
veces cuando estas letras doradas
llegaban a la línea la máquina no
procede a taparla
simplemente la máquina no hacía nada
cuando me llamaron para ayudar con el
problema lo primero que hice fue
observar el problema
ahora las latas llegaban en cualquier
habitación lo que era interesante era
que el problema sólo ocurría en las
tapas con la cinta en diagonal así como
pueden ver la imagen a la derecha más
nunca cuando lo siente está en
horizontal o vertical como la imagen a
la izquierda esto fue muy gracioso
porque porque ni bien note esto me puso
a girar todas las latas como loco a
vertical horizontal
a todo el mundo lo está viendo raro
pero lo bueno es que tenía razón el
problema solo pasaba con la cinta en
diagonal
así que junte a todo el equipo para
pensar en el porqué
en ella nos dimos cuenta que el problema
era que el color de la cinta era muy
parecido al color del láser el láser
apuntaba justamente a la cinta cuando
cuando va en diagonal como pueden ver en
la imagen es así que el actual proceder
a los del láser azul y nunca más tuvimos
problemas
esto a su vez significó una semana extra
producción disponible en el año y dos
millones de libras esterlinas o tres
millones de dólares en ventas
adicionales
además aprendimos que el color del láser
es algo que tenemos que tener en cuenta
al momento de introducir un nuevo diseño
en total tengo alrededor de 2.000 casos
de resolución problemas en mi registro
lo mejor es que esta metodología puedes
aplicar uno por cualquier persona no
tiene que ser un científico un ingeniero
o un experto en campo y segundo puede
ser puede ser aplicado en cualquier
trabajo o negocio
observar pensar lectura el secreto está
en observar perfectamente los detalles
el que quién cuándo dónde cómo
preguntar por qué por qué por qué por
qué y por qué
y finalmente asegurarte que tu solución
es aunque el problema no vuelva a
ocurrir
finalmente esta metodología es una de
las varias herramientas que llevo en
marketing ni bien entró a mi fábrica una
herramienta incluso más importante que
una llave un destornillador o martín una
herramienta que compensan mis instintos
del ser humano de que resaltar pasos y
llegar a conclusiones aproximadamente
y siento que son ociosos y que nos
impiden progresar
hoy he querido abrir mi maletín de las
metas y mostrarles cómo funciona una
para que cuando un problema los quiera
detener se sientan en control y puedan
confiadamente tomar un paso atrás para
primero observar bien el problema y
pensar en el porqué y finalmente actuar
para mejorar gracias
[Música]